okay is it okay if I touch you yeah okay
is it cool if I touch you yes Shay is it
okay if I touch you yeah okay cool I
love that idea is it cool if I touch you
yeah okay oh no no no what you just
started no no no I know exactly what
that is it's the barber that ass
couldn't send before touching you no no
no that's a no in the scale of
everything dumb that's a no that's dumb
I came to cut my hair of course you're
going to touch me how you going to do
that WiFi how you going to touch my hair
how you going to cut my hair without
touching can I touch you
yeah yeah that's what I'm here for
imagine I go to see you and you're like
can I can I touch you and I'm like no
what
then what then what do we do no what do
we do yeah imagine taking an appointment
for one 1 p.m. with Stacy you sit in the
chair can I get a can I touch you nah n
why you here what I just came here to
say no I just came here to cut my hair
can I touch you no
a yo Okay the reason okay so the reason
this is happening is because I saw the
video earlier and you know that was one
of the first time that I understood you
oh so in your goddamn phone across the
roof like oh I Chuck that [__] I oh my
day I'mma sit in a barber's chair yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
you're going to ask me can I touch oh
wow you're just doing that video to be
let's hear her let's hear her let's hear
her okay if I touch you go right ahead
and what are your pronouns he she her
thank you for asking earlier okay is it
okay if I touch you yeah okay cool and
what are your pronouns they them she I'm
glad we exchanged those yes okay I'm
glad that you came in today to give me
the opportunity to talk about what it's
like when we grow out our hair from a
shaped head mhm first things first is it
okay if I touch you and take down this
whole thing up through the top Okay cool
so is it cool if I touch you yes am I in
here yes I am right yeah I am yes cool
all right so it's cool if I touch you my
pronouns are she
they how about you my pronoun are they
them okay cool you know what and you
know what the thing is the thing is that
it's it's if we get out of this and we
got I get out of the jokes and stuff
like that and whatever what
not it's respect at the end of the day
she's respecting the person in her space
is her space that's how she wants to
operate it that's how she operates it
it's just the
elogic of you're coming to cut your hair
and ask you I'm like like G of course
you are but but if I'm being really fair
and I'm really like you know what let me
just she's operating her business on the
basis of respect I don't feel like that
I'm going to go there and she's going to
disrespect me so I can't really 100%
clowner and be
like I can't but it's a logic for me to
be like going and cut my what if I say
no you're opening of course you're going
to but maybe maybe that's just me and
that's my privilege because I'm not
triggered by a lot of by by some of the
things and to some people it triggers
them but it's just that and it's
switching that you don't want me to
touch you okay so then what I'm going to
show you well here's the scissors take
the scissors and that's how you're going
to cut your hair no shorter no shorter
I'm the professional but I'm going to te
it's just that but if we remove that
she's at the end of the day she's being
respectful so just like whatever I think
it's very performative this seems like a
performance done in front of the camera
uh you know for political brownie points
but I think it's a good business
strategy because like the kind of people
who go there you saw a lot of they them
pronouns coming out there probably
because he does his whole little ritual
and for them their political leanings
matter when they go to their Barber Shop
they're always going to maybe they're
always going to say yes but just her
asking puts them in a conference state
so you know what I cannot clown her but
I'm like oh my God to me it just seems
very counterintuitive I go to a massage
parlor I lay on the table
can I touch you I'm going look at you
funny but again again I think this is
just our reaction because the whole
consent conversation is really dumb is
really dumb in the way that they've
engaged in it okay that's that's that's
all I'm trying to say and and to give
you guys a good example okay all right
this is a YouTube video that I'll never
forget can I kiss you
yeah
get the out of
here
God it hurts my head it's so old God
damn
bro is this
okay can I put my hand here
yes you like that
mhm want to help me take off my
shirt
yo it is crazy they got that mic inside
someone's throat them sound
effects
M yeah they didn't know this is going to
be an ASMR Jesus Christ all right how'
you put a mic in your cheek and kiss
some wood can I take your shirt off no
not
yet
is you here the boom guy is right
here the
guy why why why did you breathe like
that you got to hear he got up right in
my ear he
went you got to be right you
get out get out you got in my ear you
you he got him my ear and he goes like
[Laughter]
this
go the guy with the vik is
just
[Music]
the guy with the shut up shut up shut up
oh my stomach
hurts okay oh
okay I didn't
say k
me yes
please can I kiss your neck
no no nobody does like that okay stop
stop okay I think it's good to ask for
consent I think it's good to talk to
your partner during all right I don't
think you should just assume everything
possible right it's not because she said
you can be inside her that you can take
her bum you should definitely ask for
certain things it makes sense but if
you're already kissing somebody's neck I
don't think you need to ask them if you
could kiss their chest wow all right
listen sex and intimacy a certain level
of it requires a bit of tension a little
bit of mystery a little bit doesn't mean
you just oh mystery I'm in your bum
that's not how it works but I think it's
okay to not have to ask every 5 Seconds
that's what I'm saying this is why I
said it's performative yeah I don't
think these people actually do this they
don't do that I don't believe this is
actually something that's useful I think
they do it for brownie points because it
looks good yeah and this video came out
I think it's like 2013 at a time when it
was cool to say you did this kind of
stuff some
2015 no before that it was like it was
before 20 let me see let me see I said
9 years
ago Hey listen there's a couple things
he did there that I think you should ask
yeah you kid a tie some steps you SK the
out but on the inner TI Jesus you didn't
ask for that that's [__] up my guy you
should be canceled yep you got imagine
if y'all just walk in with your wives
you're like can I hold your hand oh my
God
can you imagine you imagine you're
looking at your child hey you can you
hold my hand
please but it's like it's just in
there's whatever it's again I think
these people really start from a good
place and they just take it so far that
they just look like Looney Tunes consent
is a good thing absolutely we all agree
okay what you guys are describing is
insanity yeah no no reasonable human
does this none none
I've been in your circles they don't do
that I actually know some of the people
who shot this video I know they don't do
that you know some people that shot this
video yep oh all the people who did this
are are in the city oh [__] they this
here yeah oh yeah so all this to
say let's stop pretending it's
performance but it's fine if if it it's
I think it's a marketing standpoint so
it's it's yeah I really think it's just
they want political inclusion I think
that's what it is for them it's to their
to their political group it looks good
so they'll say the right things and this
is what this strikes me as but we want
to hear from you guys what do you all
think do y'all think that's sexy fun all
that good stuff let us know in the
comments below